I'm trying to woo you with aesthetic
laughs hello I didn't do it I didn't do
the Adele lyric ha I'm awesome hello my
name is grace I'll bake this is my
youtube channel I'm glad you made it you
should subscribe because you don't want
all of your hard work of getting here to
go to waste it's gonna go to waste
anyway so so fast it is 2016 and the
beginning of the year is when I think
most of us feel most motivated
we're inspired resolutions are a
resolute ish so I thought this would be
the absolute perfect time to give you my
list of 16 things that you can do to
have the most successful 2016 you're
already doing one of them you're living
unless someone has weekend at Bernie do
you into watching this video in which
cut that deadweight that's a bad friend
I want you here on your own choices your
own terrible terrible choices the first
and most obvious key to success are day
planners they make for great paper so
definitely don't be afraid to use them
with your hands my second tip is to look
up people that truly inspire you look up
images of them and really try to absorb
their essence don't be afraid to spend
an inappropriate amount of time doing
this I will find you
I will kill you but my next tip is to
scream sometimes Oh Oh next try really
challenging yourself to learn to sleep
standing up against the mattress that's
leaning up against your wall in a squat
this knocks out sleeping and exercise
all at once damn next I highly recommend
investing in a large whiteboard it's a
great way to write out all of your big
ideas in a place you definitely won't
miss and once your big ideas are written
down don't be afraid to start testing
them out that's the only way that dreams
become a reality
next this may sound cheesy but I think
it's so important make time to dance
like no one is watching this is time
just for you let it all out be free and
always prepared for potential murderer
next and I might be a little biased haha
but I think you should get a dog
they make great listeners for your
really big ideas okay how about this
underwear that changes color it starts
out one color and then it turns
completely brown when you need to change
it this one's a given but make time for
your friends balance is key pickles
don't forget to continue to work on
those ideas rome wasn't made into a
slightly unsafe tourist trap in a day
read great books that will inspire you
great style book calm the structure of
your working environment is so crucial
to your success create a workspace that
reflects who you are use meditation to
calm your wandering brain forgive
yourself for constantly being a [ __ ]
idiot and last but not least never ever
forget about the fans there you go there
are sixteen things to help you have a
successful 2016 I hope this helped if it
didn't I don't know
oh no my computer's been taken no that
was a chair I swear I didn't
poot out of my butthole